[Music]
[Applause]
I want to thank everybody for coming
my name is Bruce Starr I'm a talk radio
show host for those of you don't don't
know me and for the folks out in the
video land there I'm so honored to be
able to introduce dr. Joel Wallach and
for so many reasons one of the main
reasons is that dr. Joel wallet was my
first sponsor on my first radio show 25
years ago and we sort of not that we
started together because you were
abandoned we bonded right away and we
helped build each other's reputations
and and businesses you helped me I was
on the air for two years with you and we
we found each other again
at a recent Expo and it's just been
great having you in my life again and
you've been so beneficial to me being a
sponsor and a supporter of my show that
was a 95.9 FM so I want to just thank
you again for coming down to South
Florida and I appreciate it I'm gonna
put this on you you ladies and gentlemen
dr. Joel Wallach thank you
I do want to correct my name though I am
Rocky Balboa and of course I was an
athlete in in junior high in high school
in University of Missouri and so I'm
going to talk about health and fitness
and exercise if that's okay with you
guys and obviously involves a lot of
musculoskeletal stuff and and we'll talk
about that and energy and these kinds of
things and we'll have QA sort of as we
go along here okay basically what makes
me different as I do have a degree in
agriculture I'm a veterinarian I have a
post doctoral fellowship the equivalent
of a PhD in pathology and I also am a
primary care physician as an HP attic
physician licensed in Oregon and
California so you have those four
degrees and my thesis for my project for
my post doctoral fellowship which
encompass University Missouri Iowa State
University of Washington University and
my thesis was 20,000 autopsies 10
million chemistry's 10 million special
stains looking for pollution as a
contributor to causes of deaths from
natural causes
make a long story short the finding was
that the pollution had nothing to do
with deaths from natural causes
genetics had nothing to do to deaths
from natural causes regardless of the
species all vertebrates were dealing
with nutritional deficiencies every
disease you can name except for
obviously trauma and infections and
things like that but all of the
pre-existing conditions kind of things
are all due to nutritional deficiencies
and that was why I got my 1,200 page a
thesis into a hardcover book it's in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure and I'm very very proud of that
then went on to become a primary care
physician so I could use that
information to help people like I said I
did letter in junior high and high
school University in wrestling and
football I only weigh 210 pounds but I
had some advantages at 110 pounds in
that I was taking all the known
essential nutrients
per pound of body weight over a race
that came out of my study
it's what the reason why my thesis aka
book is in the Smithsonian Institution
national treasure my thesis showed that
all vertebrates require 90 essential
nutrients has thus the 90 and the 90
essential nutrients are 66 zero minerals
16 vitamins 12 amino acids 3 fatty acids
and if you're missing any of these are
they're less than optimum amount you're
going to get diseases that's what it
amounts to and this is called
epigenetics there are no genetically
transmitted diseases your genes DNA RNA
and telomeres do require minerals and
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
to do their jobs because genes DNA RNA
and telomeres are just blueprints they
cannot make things without the raw
materials so we get ourselves into
trouble when we're deficient and
unfortunately you cannot get everything
you need from your food I don't care how
well you eat I don't care how much money
if you spend for food trying to get
everything you need by eating well would
be the equivalent to putting dirt from
Texas six quarts of dirt from Texas in
your car and assuming there's going to
be some oil in that dirt from Texas
because it's dirt from Texas now an
insane person wouldn't do that to their
car but you do that to your body all the
time I'm eating well I am you're dead
okay so is that simple okay well
athletes have a great place they get to
do what they love they love their sports
and they they especially in high school
and university and and Olympics and
professional athletes I mean they get
paid to do what they love to do now
athletes you'd think they're fit they
exercise they eat well they have
dieticians they have personal trainers
that have sourced medicine doctors this
is an ideal profession as when you're
dealing with athletes however there's a
negative the average lifespan when you
take all professional athletes when you
take all professional sports combined
the average lifespan is 62 except for
football is 51
now you've all heard of sudden death and
athletes every sport cheerleaders every
sport weathers gymnastics or track or
basketball or football or boxing or
wrestling bodybuilding in America each
year about 20,000 athletes from little
peewee league guys to pop Warner's to
junior high high school professional
Olympics and so for the University if
they die they just dropped yet
they're dead before they hit the ground
ok these are caused by nutritional
deficiencies ok actually did 1700
autopsies on kids under the age of 10
that died of this one particular
deficiency because of sudden
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease you're dead before you hit the
ground when you see an athlete that died
suddenly and practice are on the field
or after they go home after the day of
playing they died at home these are
caused by deficiency of a single
nutrient this is published work 1700
autopsies if all athletes were to take
the 90 essential nutrients and avoid
certain inflammatory bad foods this
would never happen it's just that simple
and we've eliminated all these diseases
and animals livestock because we only
have health insurance for them health
insurance was the worst possible thing
for human health because doctors don't
want to cure you they want to be paid
every month by the insurance and so they
just treat your symptoms there's only
one there's only one pharmaceutical
class antibiotics that actually cure
diseases pharmaceuticals that are
antibiotics can cure syphilis Salmonella
staph strep bacterial pneumonia
bacterial meningitis but that's it all
other prescription drugs are designed to
relieve symptoms one pain reliever now
called opioids is very popular and at
night and 2015 52,000 Americans died
from overdoses you're primarily
teenagers dying from overdoses of
opioids prescription opioids
and what do we do what do we do we'll
stop prescribing the damn things is that
simple but they're so good as pain
relievers well there's a lot of pain
relievers or payment leaders that are
not addictive do a better job action and
opioids but doctors purposely prescribed
addictive drugs so you keep coming back
every month to renew your prescription
because you're now addicted my doctor
wouldn't do that I love my doctor
damn you're dead okay and so in addition
to fitness and exercise people need to
pay attention to the 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 mr.
rivetti houses we actually have a sports
drink I'll tell you about some of the
athletes I dealt with and one our sports
drink was invented for a guy by the name
of Theo Ratliff he played basketball for
the Atlanta Hawks me remember his name
yeah and a wonderful guy I met him 20
years ago when he had lost his position
on the Atlanta Hawks because he had bone
to bone arthritis in both his knees and
his cartilage popped off his hip and he
caught a pasture and regulation game
broke his wrist and they said this guy's
too fragile to play professional sports
and he was given the bum's rush and told
he couldn't play anymore and took his
contract away and Andy young from the
civil rights movement also the mayor of
Atlanta at that time he was the
ambassador United Nations under
President Jimmy Carter I had rebuilt his
knees he had bone to bone arthritis and
didn't want the surgery so I rebuilt his
knees helped in regrow his cartilage and
he was always sending people to me well
he sent Theo Ratliff to me so si si can
help in and we gave him a program which
we now call today the healthy bone and
joint pack is designed for all
musculoskeletal things and is designed
to support and promote maintenance and
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebra bone matrix bone itself and we
deal with all musculoskeletal things
everything ranging from arthritis to
trauma fractures I see a lot of Special
Forces guys a lot of Navy SEALs rebuild
them but Thea Ratliff his it was a fun
guy six foot 11 I'm only five foot six
so he had a lot of fun together
I rebuilt his knees and his hip and got
his bones strong enough to wear 90 days
after we met he was able to go back and
get his position they came all the tests
and everything he passed some with
flying colors and one of the things I
did was invent a sports drink for him
called rebound it has a hundred
nutrients in it including the nutrients
necessary to prevent sudden heart death
and athletes sudden deaths from ruptured
aneurysms which happens unfortunately
too often in young athletes and he's one
of our spokespersons he's a great great
trainer and teacher for our youngevity
associates and customers and and young
athletes all over the world and to make
a long story short when he got his
position back at the Hawks his first
3-year contract was 40 million dollars
he made a lot more than that or the next
11 years that he played he retired from
the LA Lakers and his wife Christina
loves me yeah they're a great couple and
their daughter is 6 foot 2 and so it's
just really a beautiful couple and
beautiful family just love them to
pieces and like I say he's a great
spokesman for us another individual I
helped to as an athlete was a lady by
the name of delecia Jones she was with
his woman's Olympic basketball team that
won the three Olympics in a row or a 15
year or 12 year period whatever it was
and she was with him with her first two
Olympics and she got gold medals with
the rest the team and then training for
the third one she tore her hamstring and
her Achilles tendon on the right side
and the surgeons have put her back here
to look these are such catastrophic
injuries we recommend you not play
anymore
training is too rough if you tear these
again we will not be able to help you
will spend the rest of your life in a
wheelchair well she went to Andy young
he said well the only person who might
be able to help use wallach so she came
to see me now she's six foot five okay
and great lovely lady and she always
wears eight-inch high heels
okay so now she's seven foot two and so
to make a long story short rebuild her
and she got her third gold medal okay
and so she's a great volunteer coach for
women athletes that we deal with and
then there's another woman athlete by
the name of Kelly Herron University of
Memphis
she was all-american basketball player
on the basketball team and a half way
through her two years with them and she
was an all-american because she could
hit the three pointers from half-court
with one hand
nine out of ten times and she had a
teammate
Jenny Jackson who and both of them are
like six two and she would feed her the
ball if she knew they knew each other so
well she knew how to feed her the ball
so she could make that shot there was
just a great little thing a couple so
the speaker team mates and but miss
Kelly at that at the end of the two
years she had torn the labrum on her
rotator cuff and she couldn't raise her
hand above her her waist we should want
I don't want the surgery and all the
surgeons are gathering around they want
to be the one to do this
labrum rotator cuff surgery on an
all-american athlete right and she
didn't know I'm not gonna do surgery I
just want to rest it out a little bit
see if just resting it will heal it well
just got worse and worse worse so one of
her friends bought her one of my
lectures and she came up to me and she
says I'm not interested in magic berries
and beans and things as well no we're a
little beyond that and she decided to
try it and in 90 days she was able to do
everything perfectly again hear shots
and went back and did her thing for a
while now she's one of our distributors
and and just a great great volunteer
coach with Mike Glenn from the Atlanta
Hawks
he was the stinger Mike Glenn actually
he hit jump shots and he holds a record
with the Hawks for the jump shot two
pointers and he had to quit after like
six years of playing with him I believe
because he had bone to bone arthritis
and he said I it had your healthy bone
and joint pack I'd still be playing
basketball for the Hawks he said because
I rebuilt him but he volunteer coaches
for deaf basketball camps and miss Kelly
here and the one from the University of
Memphis the all-american girl she
volunteers with him because a lot of
girls and boys in that deaf basketball
camp so we have a lot of great stuff
these athletes do but the most
remarkable thing they do for these other
athletes they train is they make sure
they're taking their 90 essential
nutrients that are using the rebound
with 100 nutrients in it instead of the
Gatorade with 2 and powered with 6
[Music]